.
RIGHT NOW PRESIDENT BIDEN IS
HEADED TO LOS ANGELES TO CONVENE
AND LEAD THE SUMMIT OF THE
NATIONS.
LEADERS ARE NOT ATTENDING.
THOSE SNUBS EXTEND TO EXCLUDE
CUBA, VENEZUELA AND NICARAGUA.
THEY SAID MONDAY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION DID NOT QUOTE
BELIEVE DICTATORS SHOULD BE
INVITED.
JOINING ME NOW IS A NATIONAL
COUNCIL COORDINATOR, ADMIRAL
KIRBY, A FORMER PRESS SECRETARY
AND SERVED AT THE STATE
DEPARTMENT.
JOHN, GOOD TO SEE YOU.
SO THE PRESIDENT IS WHEELS UP,
MIGRATION IS ONE OF THE KEY
ISSUES.
YOU HAVE A BOYCOTT BY LEADERS
THAT TAKE OFFENSE, THEY THINK
THE UNITED STATES WAS WRONG NOT
TO INVITE CUBA, NOT TO INVITE
VENEZUELA, NOT TO INVITE NICK
NICARAGUA.
>> I THINK THE PRESIDENT TOOK AN
APPROACH HERE.
THE APPROACH OF THE SUMMIT OF
THE AMERICAS IS FOR DEMOCRACIES
TO TALK ABOUT CHALLENGES IN THE
WESTERN HEMISPHERE, TO WESTERN
SECURITY.
THE PRESIDENT FELT THE FIRST
PRESIDENT TO GO SINCE 2015, IT
WAS IMPORTANT THAT DEMOCRACIES
GO.
HE UNDERSTANDS OTHER PEOPLE HAVE
DIFFERENT VIEWS.
THAT'S THE THINGS ABOUT
DEMOCRACIES, HE RESPECTS THE
DECISIONS OF SOME HEADS OF
STATES NOT TO COME.
I WILL REMIND MORE THAN 25 HEAD
OF STATES WILL GO AND 68
DELEGATIONS.
EVEN SOME OF THOSE COUNTRIES NOT
SENDING THEIR HEADS OF ESTATE
ARE IN FACT SENDING GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS TO PARTICIPATE IN WHAT
WILL BE A VERY ROBUST SET OF
DISCUSSIONS.
>> YOU ARE SAYING THIS IS A
PRINCIPLE MOVE NOT TO STAND UP
FOR DEMOCRACY?
SOME SAY IT'S HYPOCRISY.
YESTERDAY, THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY SAYS SAUDI ARABIA IS
AN IMPORTANT PARTNER.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES IS ON THE RECORD OF
CALLING THEM A PARIAH BEFORE HE
WAS PRESIDENT.
WEBSTER DEFINES PARIAH AS ONE
WHO IS DESPISED OR REJECTED AN
OUTCAST.
HOW CAN ONE BEING DESPISED OR
REJECTED AN IMPORTANT PARTNER?
>> THE PRESIDENT WAS RESPONDING
TO THE KILLING OF KHASHOGGI AND
THIS ADMINISTRATION PUT INTO
PLACE ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES
AND HE BELIEVES IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR HIM TO BE WILLING AND ABLE
TO MEET WITH LEADERS ALL ACROSS
THE WORLD, NO MATTER WHO THEY
ARE OR WHO THEY REPRESENT IF, IN
FACT, IT'S GOING TO IMPROVE U.S.
NATIONAL SECURITY INTERESTS.
IN THIS CASE, THE MR. PRESIDENT
BELIEVES THAT ITSELF THE CASE.
WE DON'T HAVE A TRIP OR MEETINGS
TO SPEAK TO SPECIFICALLY.
BUT THE SAUDI ARABIANS ARE KEY
ACROSS THE REGION AND, QUITE
FRANKLY, ACROSS THE WORLD IN
TERMS OF HELPING OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY INTERESTS.
LOOK, OUR PILOTS HAVE FLOWN WITH
THEIR PILOTS, STRIKING MISSILES,
TARGETS AGAINST ISIS.
OUR SAILORS AND SHIPS SAILED
WITH THEIR SHIPS AND COUNTER
TERRORISM MISSIONS, BECAUSE OF
U.S. DIPLOMATIC ENGAGEMENT, WE
WERE ABLE TO GET THIS TRUCE IN
YEMEN IN PLACE, NOW IN FORCE FOR
TWO MONTHS.
SO THERE IS AN AWFUL LOT TO TALK
TO SAUDIS ABOUT.
THE CROWN PRINCE IS ALSO THE
DEFENSE MINISTER OF THAT VERY
IMPORTANT PARTNER.
>> I GUESS IT THAT PRESIDENTS
SOMETIMES HAVE TO SIT DOWN WITH
BAD ACTORS TO DO IMPORTANT
BUSINESS.
BUT THE CHALLENGE HERE IS THAT
JOE BIDEN AS A CANDIDATE AND JOE
BIDEN AS A PRIVATE CITIZEN AND
JOE BIDEN AS VICE PRESIDENT
BEFORE, LISTEN, THIS IS JOE
BIDEN IN 2018, A PRIVATE CITIZEN
AFTER THE KHASHOGGI KILLING.
BEATING UP ON DONALD TRUMP
SAYING HE WAS PROBABLY THE
SAUDIS.
>> AFTER A COLD BLOODED MURDER
OF JOURNALIST GIVING THE CROWN
PRINCE OF SAUDI ARABIA THE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT.
LOOK AT THE EXAMPLE THAT SETS
AROUND THE WORLD.
FORGET WHAT IT DOES HERE.
WHAT IT DOES AROUND THE WORLD.
PEOPLE WONDER, WHAT HAS BECOME
OF US?
>> AND THEN, JOHN, THERE IS ALSO
THIS FROM THE DEMOCRATIC
CONVENTION IN 20.
SAME ISSUE.
>> I'LL BE A PRESIDENT WHO WILL
STAND WITH OUR ALLIES AND FRIEND
AND MAKE IT CLEAR TO OUR
ADVERSARIES THE DAYS OF COZYING
UP TO DICTATORS IS OVER.
I WILL ALWAYS STAND FOR OUR
VALUES OF HUMAN RIGHTS AND
DIGNITY.
I'LL WORK IN COMMON PURPOSE FOR
A MORE SECURE, PEACEFUL AND
PROSPEROUS WORLD.
>> NOW, I GET IT AGAIN, THERE IS
REAL POLITICS, HISTORY
BENEFITTED FROM THE PRESIDENT
DOING THAT WITH GORBECHEV,
CANDIDATES SAY THINGS THAT BLACK
AND WHITE PRESIDENTS HAVE TO
DEAL IN NUANCE?
>> NO, I DON'T THINK SO, NOT AT
ALL.
LOOK, THE PRESIDENT WAS HONEST
AFTER JAMAL KHASHOGGI WAS
KILLED.
HIS ADMINISTRATION WE PUT
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES IN,
PARTS OF THEIR GOVERNMENT FOR
THAT BUT THEY ARE AN IMPORTANT
PARTNER IN A REGION THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY STILL VITAL TO OUR
INTERESTS.
AFTER A MEETING THAT HASN'T BEEN
SET, I WILL TELL YOU THE
PRESIDENT WILL BE COMPLETELY
UNAFRAID TO HAVE HONEST, CANDID
DISCUSSIONS WITH LEADERS AROUND
THE WORLD WITH ALMOST EVERYTHING
AND THOSE WHERE WE HAVE
DIFFERENCES.
THAT'S WHERE THE LEADERSHIP IS
ABOUT AND WHEN YOU CAN DISAGREE
ABOUT THINGS AND HAVE AN HONEST
DISCUSSION ABOUT HUMAN RIGHTS
AND CIVIL RIGHTS AND STILL BE
ABLE TO GET THINGS DONE.
>> I KNOW I THINK YOUR THIRD DAY
AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
YOU ARE IN A NEW POSITION.
YOU SAY A MEETING THAT HASN'T
BEEN SCHEDULED.
THE PRESIDENT'S OWN STAFF
ANONYMOUSLY.
BEFORE YOU TOOK THIS JOB SAID
THE MEETING WAS SET.
THE PRESIDENT.
, WAS ASKED ABOUT IT PUBLICLY
AND PUSHED BACK.
IS THAT A PART OF THE PROBLEM,
JOE BIDEN RAN SAYING I AM THE
ADULT WHO KNOWS HOW TO RUN THE
GOVERNMENT.
THERE SEEMS TO BE A LOT OF
CONFUSION WITHIN YOUR WEST WING.
>> ONE COMMANDER IN CHIEF, ONE
PRESIDENT.
HE GETS TO DETERMINE WHO HE WILL
MEET WITH.
WHEN HE WILL MEET WITH THEM.
LOOK, SAUDI ARABIA AGAIN IS AN
IMPORTANT PARTNER.
WE WILL SPEND TIME WITH OUR
LEADERSHIP AND ADDRESS ISSUES IN
THE REGION AND AROUND THE WORLD
THAT INTERSECT WITH OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY INTERESTS.
LOOK, THE SCHEDULE WILL WORK
ITSELF OUT.
WHEN WE HAVE SOMETHING TO
ANNOUNCE AND A MEETING TO TALK
ABOUT, WE'LL CERTAINLY DO THAT.
>> I WANT TO SNEAK IN ONE QUICK
QUESTION ABOUT UKRAINE.
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY SPOKE TO THE
GERMAN CHANCELLOR, THERE WAS A
CONVERSATION THE GERMANS SAID
THEY WOULD DO ANYTHING TO HELP
WITH THIS GLOBAL FOOD CRISIS
BECAUSE THE UKRAINIAN GRAIN IS
HELD UP.
THERE HAVE BEEN CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT IS THERE SOME WAY TO USE
NATO FORCES OR WESTERN FORCES TO
HELP GET THOSE SHIPMENTS OUT?
CAN THAT BE DONE WITHOUT
COORDINATING WITH RUSSIA?
IS THAT A PIPE DREAM OR A
PROBABLY?
>> LOOK, I THINK EVERYBODY IS
FOCUSED ON THE FOOD INSECURITY
AND THE EMBARGO RUSSIA PUT IN
PLACE OF GETTING GRAIN AND FOOD
STUFF OUT OF UKRAINE.
ALL OF US ARE HAVING ACROSS THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY ABOUT
HOW TO DO THIS.
THERE IS LOTS OF DIFFERENT
IDEAS.
I DON'T WANT TO GET AHEAD OF
DECISIONS THAT HAVEN'T BEEN MADE
YET.
WE HAVE TO BE MINDFUL IT IS A
WAR ZONE, THE BLACK SEA IS
OCCUPIED BY NAVY WAR SHIPS.
NO DECISIONS HAVE BEEN MADE.
BUT I REQUEST TELL YOU THAT
EVERYBODY SHEER VERY, VERY
FOCUSED ON THE FOOD, POTENTIAL
FOOD CRISIS LOOMING BY WHAT
RUSSIA IS DOING.
RUSSIA IS WEAPONIZING FOOD.
NOT JUST TO HURT THE PEOPLE OF
UKRAINE AND THEIR ECONOMY BUT TO
HURT THE REST OF EUROPE AS WELL.
SO IT'S A BIG FOCUS